[Musik]
5.000 am 12. Dame bei einem Weltraum-Vorsprechen,
wie Sie ihn gesehen haben - Lieblinge in einem Hollywood
und Erfüllung der Biografie Telefon
Mary Shelley Sie sprechen von
Frankenstein, wenn Sie ärgerlich sind Film er
perfektioniert den Kandidaten im Charakter -
Mandel alleinige Anführerin  Arbeit in Anaheim,
wie es ist, dass die Besetzung
sehr unterschiedlich ist. In den
Leads nah und fern in den Top
50 der Klinik ist unsere Dschihad-Schwester gekommen
- Mansour, oh, vielen Dank, Erin, ja,
es gibt eine Menge  Dinge, in denen ich mich verändert habe,
und die Filmindustrie zu Hause in Saudi-
Arabien, als ich filmte, war gerade 2012,
dort war das Land getrennt, und
jedes Mal, wenn ich rausging und auf die Straße ging, war
ich in einem Van und und ich war es
nicht  Ich kann deswegen mit der Crew zusammen sein
, aber jetzt
öffnet sich das Land und es gibt Platz für Kunst auf
den Straßen und und ich habe einfach
den Rücken frei und muss nicht
im Van sein und manchmal haben, selbst wenn wir
sind an einem ort wo es
restr  Ich mag und mag eine konservative
Person, die keinen Aufruhr auf der
Straße mag oder so, dass wir
die Polizei rufen werden und die Polizei uns
Schutz gibt, also diese Art von Rechtsschutz
, die es mir viel einfacher gemacht hat, ihn zu bearbeiten
Weil es wirklich schwierig ist, einen Film zu machen,
besonders an einem Ort wie Saudi-Arabien,
wo wir keine komplette
Infrastruktur für Filme haben, wir haben
keine Casting-Agenten oder Location-
Scouter und Dinge, die die
Branche viel einfacher machen, also ja, das war es  Eine
saisonal einfachere Sanga Hardy-Sache
ist nicht in unserem Bogen, nein - besuchte eine Insel,
wenn es sich um ein Casting für Kakaako- und
Tretinoin-Film handelte. Das Casting war sehr
schwierig.
Milas irani, die die Hauptrolle
als aufstrebende Fernsehschauspielerin spielte, als ich einige
davon sah  ihre Arbeit und ich mochte sie wirklich
und es war einfacher für uns, die Hauptbesetzung zu finden
, aber alle anderen waren keine
professionellen Schauspieler, einschließlich des Mädchens
, das Selma und den Film spielte, und
Selmas Charakter hat
viel Spaß  und hat viel Humor und es war
wirklich schwer, jemanden zu finden, der
das landen kann, und ich benutze es wie eine
Instagram-App
Skizzen und so und sie
kam herein und gab ein wirklich erstaunliches
Vorsprechen, bei dem sie sich selbst nicht
ernst nahm, was sie war, und sie stellte sich
selbst da draußen heraus, und deshalb bekam
sie die Rolle, und ich habe das Gefühl, dass ich
Schauspielerinnen wie diese bewundere  Sind sie bereit
, sich da draußen zu zeigen, besonders
Saudi-Arabien wäre nicht sehr
konservativ und schüchtern, und sie ist
nicht so, dass es Leute gibt, die
in Saudia haben, Miss Ava Cossacks gesehen haben,
es ist teilweise geschnitten, du nicht  einladen
vision gedanken in kontext kennt mich ein kerl
ich bin irin unten damit ich weiß
wie ich gut leben sollte
sie sagt durch gedanken dass
seit der idee robin natürlich ja
wie künstler so lange saudi arabien habe
ich eine sehr durchgemacht  konservatives Gesicht
m  Mit der konservativen
islamischen sehr islamischen konservativen
Ideologie geht es darum, Frauen und
Arthur aus dem öffentlichen Raum auszuschließen, und so wurden
weibliche Darsteller nie
respektiert, nie gemocht, nie behandelt, es
war kein Beruf, den Sie für
Ihre Tochter oder Kinder anstreben, das ist es  Nur wenige,
viele der Schauspielerinnen tun es, weil
sie finanziell etwas
in einem Beruf brauchen, aber jetzt hat sich viel geändert
, und wir versuchen
, ihnen gerne Auszeichnungen zu geben und versuchen,
ihm Respekt zu verschaffen, wenn es darum geht  Zur
Performance-Kunst Ich sehe Moment Art vac
netter Feinschmecker Hilfe - sie leben
Gemüse meine Ästhetik ist im Film auch
treyton diejenigen es in invitin thailand dieser
film ist einer der deccan-körbe schreib
mir eine flasche ich weiß nicht, es besteht kein
risiko  video Ich denke, dann haben wir einen Fernseher, also haben
wir viele Schauspielerinnen, es besteht kein
Risiko, dass es ein Beruf ist,
wie es Schauspielerinnen und
Sängerinnen und Frauen gibt, aber
es ist genau wie t  Das soziale Stigma,
das mit einem solchen Beruf
einhergeht, und Sie möchten, dass
eine
Schauspielerin wie eine
Ärztin behandelt wird oder wie eine Anwältin behandelt wird, hat
ähnlichen Respekt und bringt diesen
Respekt zurück nach Saudi-Arabien  Für
die Künstler in Saudi-Arabien ist es sehr
wichtig und ich denke, jetzt gibt es eine
Bewegung zur Stärkung von Künstlern, wie auch
ich selbst. Ich fühle mich
als Filmemacher stärker und ich kann insbesondere, dass
Kino jetzt illegal ist, eine Genehmigung beantragen und einen
Schrott beantragen  Ich kann in Saudi-Arabien drehen, das kann
ich, aber es ist nicht so wie
früher, als ich 2012 zu einem nassen Schuss geschossen habe.
Wenn Sie auf der Straße
sind, fühlen Sie sich zerbrechlich und Ihr Arm in Ihrem Arm wird
irgendwie gejagt, und Sie fühlen sich nicht sicher,
selbst wenn einige  konservative Person kommt
und bittet uns zu gehen, auch wenn sie
keinen offiziellen Titel haben, sie hatten
immer noch mehr Macht auf der Straße als Künstler und
jetzt werden Künstler mit mehr
Legalität behandelt und wir haben mehr Macht, nein zu sagen,
ich existiere  Die Straßen sind
so, wie Sie auf der Straße existieren, also ist das
wichtig, der Mengenwissenschaftler, und
er sagte Einfügung von Stockton Kagame,
ich denke, es war sehr schnell, aber auch wie
Saudi-Arabien ist eine sehr junge Bevölkerung
und ein Großteil der Bevölkerung als
unter 25 Jahren, und diese
Menschen wie diese Generation wuchsen mit den
sozialen Medien auf, sie wurden Teil der großen
Welt, und ich denke, dass Veränderungen sehr
wichtig sind, um ihren
Bedürfnissen gerecht zu werden, sie wollen einfach nur essen gehen und
Musik hören  und viele der
Mädchen wollen nicht verheiratet sein oder die
Hälfte wollen sich ihre Partner aussuchen
und sie
wollen ihr normales Leben ändern, und ich denke, es
ist sehr wichtig, Kunst an einen
Ort wie Saudi zu bringen  Arabien, denn wenn Sie
eine Zivilisation mitbringen und aufbauen wollen, die
in der Lage ist, einen
warmen, offenen und lernenden Menschen zu haben,
können Sie dies nicht tun, ohne
Kunst und Musik und Film und
Literatur und so weiter zu bringen  Das ist wirklich
die Grundlage für eine Kultur. Sehen Sie, wie Männer
fühlen und interviewen Sie. Ich bin Evita Petalled.
Sehen Sie die Kommunistin und Eva Ha Alan Elton
Ich
bin in einer kleinen Stadt aufgewachsen und meine Eltern
sprachen nicht einmal Englisch und dort, aber
sie waren nett, sie haben mich unterstützt, sie
meine Eltern nie, ich, nie, ich komme aus
einer großen Familie, wie ich 12 Geschwister habe, die mein
Vater und meine Mutter nie erzählt haben  Ich, ich bin,
mein Bruder hat mehr Rechte und und und ich
habe mich nie gezwungen, sie zu nutzen, sie haben
mich nie gezwungen, gut zu sein, sie wollten, dass ich
wie ein Ingenieur oder wie ein Arzt bin
Klasse und wir legen Wert auf Bildung
, einen Beruf und all
das, was ein Teil von uns ist, aber meine Mutter
liebte es immer noch zu singen und mein Vater war
Dichter, also schätzen wir die Kunst wirklich, aber
wann immer ich als Kind in
Saudi-Arabien draußen stand  Als Saudi-Arabien
konservativ war, wurde ich besonders in der Schule mit einer anderen Realität konfrontiert, die so war
, als ob ich immer dachte, wie
die Stimme einer Frau, dies muss leise sein,
und Sie müssen immer mit der
Frau arbeiten, Sie können Männern nicht ausgesetzt werden, und
ich denke, was ist  Es passiert jetzt, wie es ist,
dass Mädchen jetzt ermutigt werden,
sich von diesen traditionellen Regeln zu lösen,
und sie diversifizieren den Arbeitsbereich,
in dem Frauen nicht nur mit
Frauen arbeiten und die sehr segregiert sind, wie ich
jetzt ins Einkaufszentrum und nach Saudi-Arabien gehe und
so  ist eine Menge Kassierer und eine Menge
Verkäufer und die höchste Dichte
an Uhrenkram auf den Mayonnaise
-Filmwiderständen, die vergessen wurden, ging an diesen
großartigen Sheikh Chris Curti, der existiert, aber
ich bin so sehr für mich, dass er vielleicht in kleinen
Städten existiert und solche Sachen, aber  Ich denke,
es ändert sich viel Ich denke, die Saudis
Society tut mir leid, es tut mir leid, es ist eine Gesellschaft
und Transformation und und in Bewegung,
also ist es wirklich so, aber es gibt
immer noch viele Werte wie viele  von Werten,
die sehr traditionell darin sind,
Frauen und einen bestimmten Ort zu sehen
und nicht, und um diese Werte zu ändern,
braucht man wirklich Zeit, es ist nicht nur so, dass zum
Beispiel Frauen jetzt nicht alleine reisen können,
ohne die Erlaubnis ihres männlichen
Vormunds, Dinge wie diese
Ich bin mir sicher, viele saudische Frauen
haben Fragen, ob ich alleine reisen würde
, wie sich das auf meinen
Ruf auswirken würde, wie sich das auf mein
soziales Leben auswirken würde, wie sich das auswirken würde, also gibt es
so viele Dinge, die sich ändern müssen, und
Wie Frauen die Welt sehen und wie
ihre Familien und Menschen
sie in ihrem Leben stärken. Es ändert nicht nur
die Regeln, sondern auch
die alltäglichen Werte, was meiner
Meinung nach wichtiger ist, weil es Frauen wirklich gibt,
wie sie sind  wie
ich komme Ich bin in Saudi-Arabien aufgewachsen, war
konservativ und es gab so viele
Regeln, dass ich nicht fahren konnte. Ich konnte
nichts anderes tun, als eine unterstützende Familie zu haben,
die sehr liberale
Werte hatte  Dass sie sich selbst
auferlegten, erlaubte mir zu sein, wer ich heute bin, und ich
denke, diese Werte, was wir sind, was wir
anstreben sollten, um sie für die Menschen einzubringen,
und es braucht viel Zeit
Initiative zu
Miriam und menschlichen Anzeigen in der
Berührung von Annas Vorsprechen Kunden in einer Notiz für die
Klinik von Thomas Newton sagte, dass es wichtig ist,
das zu große Vertrauen in ihre Beziehung
in Museen
sanft zu zerstreuen, um Curlin in diesen beiden Enden auf Kandidaten zu kribbeln,
wenn Sie  Nicht
viel dagegen, wir werden noch nicht außerhalb der
Saison stehen, Film auf
ja, aber hoch anhaltend, ich kann in
Saudia spielen, im Kopf, die Herzen beißen
sehr kompetent und herenga, mein Hund, ich
denke, es hat ein ähnliches wie -
du  man muss eine Agenda haben, die man haben
muss wie überall und und Ironie
wie es eine perfekte Kandidatin ist, dass sie
nicht diese Erfahrung hat, um
wirklich Politikerin zu sein, aber sie hatte das Herz
dafür und das ist nicht die Hauptsache
wie Sie  brauche ap  Politikerin, die ein
Herz hat und die Welt zu tun hat, um erfolgreich zu sein,
und so können viele Frauen wie jetzt Frauen in
Saudi-Arabien für ein Amt kandidieren und
sie können wählen, aber viele
Frauen sind schüchtern, um so hoch zu gehen
wie Positionen, die im
Rampenlicht stehen und auch vor dem Scheitern zurückschrecken,
aber es ist sehr wichtig
für uns Frauen, uns dorthin zu versetzen, und
ich denke, das Scheitern ist Teil
der Reise, auf der ich scheitere, ist genauso
wichtig wie der Erfolg und  Nur wenn
wir uns da draußen präsentieren, werden die
Leute Frauen und
Führungspositionen sehen, sei es in CEOs oder
in der Politik, in der Lokalpolitik oder als
Filmemacher. Sie müssen diese
Initiative ergreifen, um Ihre
Komfortzone zu verlassen und so  Ich denke, viel von ihrem
Fachwissen bekommt sie Texte und jetzt haben
wir viele soziale Medien, und ich denke,
der Herr
mag die Existenz des Internets,
um eine enorme Bildungsquelle
für viele Saudis zu schaffen, weil sie das Gefühl haben,
dass es das ist  ein Ort, an dem Menschen
kann sich treffen und kann reden und kann über dinge diskutieren
das ist ermächtigung für entjungferung im
politischen englischen
lichtlied garcia mujer como estas von albin hager
es redet auch erwachsene satire
daher innig drin sieh es hier
obwohl is und selbstermächtigung uns da
schon bekannt vorkam  und ausländisch ausländisch
verkäuflich Kommentar mm-hmm Ich denke, es ist
beides, es ist so, als ob Sie im Nahen
Osten ein sehr komplizierter Ort sind, von dem Sie nicht sagen können,
dass er von hier oder
dort oder von dort kommt, es gibt viele
Faktoren, die
Sie angreifen können  zu ändern und zu der Situation beizutragen,
was passiert. Ich denke,
es gibt viele junge, gebildete saudische
Frauen, die bessere
Jobs haben wollen, und wir wollen Träume haben und und
und und all das führt zu Veränderungen, aber
was auch immer  Ich denke, es ist
wichtig, dass wie viele Frauen
und die Politik oder ihr festgelegtes Recht
mm-hmm,
wie viel Vertrauen die Öffentlichkeit hat
und eine Frau wählt, die einen Feind macht
und für sie ausgeht  Eis wie dieses
ist nicht sehr viel und wir haben es an
Orten wie Kuwait und Ägypten gesehen, wo
Frauen mehr und längere politische
Erfahrungen haben, aber sie haben nicht viel,
wie die breite Öffentlichkeit
Frauen und Führung im Allgemeinen nicht vertraut  und
es ist immer noch so, dass wir
in den anderen Staaten
und in Europa und im Westen sehr ähnliche Probleme haben, und Holloway
Clinton ist wie ein echtes Beispiel dafür, wie
Frauen, die fähig sind, manchmal
die Ziellinie wegen
vieler Vorurteile nicht erreichen können, wenn sie es tun  kommt zu Frauen und
Führungspositionen, aber ähm,
wir hätten diese kollektive
Geschichte schreiben und den Erfolg von Frauen feiern sollen,
und ich denke, wir zum Beispiel in
Saudi-Arabien haben so etwas wie die erste weibliche
Botschafterin in den USA, die eine Frau ist,
und es ist eine so wichtige Position  und
das ist, denke ich, stärkt andere Frauen und
sieht, dass ich es vielleicht schaffen kann, vielleicht kann ich, ich kann, ich
kann, ich kann erfolgreich sein, also
könnte es ermutigen, Beispiele wie dieses zu haben, da er
auch ich zum Frieden aufrufe  Das
Eva-Bewusstsein ist nicht unzureichend, unsere
Teixeira, sie ist früh.
Ich sehe mich nicht wirklich als Vorbild,
aber ich sehe mich selbst. Was ich
gerne tun würde, was die Leute von meiner
Erfahrung zu Hause mitnehmen würden, ist,
etwas zu tun, weil Sie es wollen  Du hast eine
Leidenschaft dafür und das ist es, was du Ich habe
angefangen, Filme zu machen, wo es keine
Industrie gibt und die Leute
mich in der Zeitung verspottet haben, als hätten wir keinen
Film, welche Art von Film, wie du weißt,
da war, hat mich niemand ernst genommen
Ich habe es wirklich nicht getan
Ich hatte wirklich nicht das Gefühl, dass ich
Erfolg haben werde Ich hatte nicht das Gefühl, dass ich eines Tages
ein Filmemacher sein werde mit Ihnen sprechen oder in
die Schweiz gehen und versuchen, den Film zu promoten
Ich habe nie  Ich dachte so, aber ich
machte Filme, nur weil Filme machen,
nur weil es mir diese Befriedigung gab,
und es ist fast wie eine
Therapie für mich, und ich stellte sicher, dass
es und Dokumentarfilme wissen würden, wer
das begrenzte Budget und ich versuchte, nur
eine Geschichte zu erzählen, tat  Es ist nicht leicht, auf ein
Don't arou zu zielen  Als Assistentin, eine Mutter, sehen
Sie, wie Sie im Film unsere Ausbildung, unser
Engagement und unsere persönliche Agentur kennen.
Einiges von Blumen. Ich bekomme viel Unterstützung
von Ronan, und ich denke, das ist es, was ich denke,
und wir müssen diese Schwesternschaft kultivieren
und wir brauchen  Um auch eine kollektive
Geschichte für uns und ein Vermächtnis wie Mary
Shelley zum Beispiel zu schaffen, war ich wirklich aufgeregt
, einen Film wie diesen zu machen, und sie ist so
anders als ich, sie ist eine britische
Energie, sie, der Film ist eine Periode und all das
, aber ich denke, sie ist es  Eine der wenigen
Frauen, die Science-Fiction geschaffen hat,
wie sie in Jane Austen kam, sie ist eine
Zeitgenossin von Jane Austen, und Jane
Austen schrieb alles über
Eifersucht und Liebe und häusliche Sphäre,
aber sie entschied sich dafür, etwas zu schreiben, das
philosophisch gesehen sehr viel von Ellen abspritzt  die
Vorstellungen und die Religion in ihr und ihrer Zeit
und und und wir sollten behaupten, dass
viele Leute sagen, das Buch ist
Franks eisernes Buch, es ist wie männlich, aber
es ist wirklich so, es ist ein direktes
Ergebnis ihrer Erfahrung  ce als Frau und der
Verlust mit einer anstrengenden Beziehung
zu ihrem Ehemann und Verlust eines Kindes und
all das, was das Monster geschaffen hat und und und
diese Dinge müssen wir reinigen und
wir müssen diese Geschichte unter uns haben
und wir möchten zusammenkommen  und
unterstützen uns gegenseitig, wo ist es eine
Führungskraft oder ein Produzent oder und wir schaffen das
, und selbst wenn es jetzt nicht existiert,
sollten wir es kultivieren und uns bemühen
, diese Art von Solidarität zu haben Dungeons
Tatsumaki Buddy Manor Unterdrückung im
Weltraum auf Tour aber  das menschliche Herrenhaus die
Atmosphäre in eine Qual
erstens Gesundheit der Teufel Comenzará haben
ist kinetisch Isaac gut er ich erzähle
wann passiert ist und ihre beiden jungen
Frauen fühlen sich sogar auf die Göttin die Uber
sie sollte in der Nähe von Arkham Stunden
lernen Kommandant Art Befehlsgrenze
lernen  in Dublin und Elemente arbeiten hora hot
in the und Regina Prototyp in Mouseland
zielen nicht einmal nach unten Gedanken die Fähigkeit
konservative nicht Sitzung Euratom
nein, ich bin sicher, wie ich sicher bin, wenn Sie  geh und
studiere woanders und du kommst zurück,
du wirst anders, denn wie an einer
Universität werden Universitätsjahre wirklich
aufgebaut, wer du bist, und du wirst
einer Menge Bildung ausgesetzt und viel wirst du
definitiv ändern. Ich denke, junge Menschen
entscheiden sich immer mehr für und  wählen Sie
aus der Tradition und sie wollen ein
normaleres Leben haben, in dem sie die
Beziehungen, insbesondere zwischen den
Geschlechtern, gerechter gestalten, und aber ich
denke, wir müssen sie auch zum Beispiel bringen,
und ich bin Feministin, aber ich habe mich nie dafür
entschieden, Filme zu machen, in denen Männer sind  Der
ultimative Bösewicht Alda, der böse Vater
und der Film, und der Film ist sehr
offen, leise und freundlich und
unterstützt seine Kinder und hat einen eigenen Traum,
und ich finde es sehr
wichtig, diese Art von
Männlichkeit in der Mitte zu feiern  Osten und stellen Sie
es in den Vordergrund und in die Mitte und Filme und
Popkultur und all das, was wir
im Nahen Osten ausgesetzt haben, und was
Männlichkeit und Fernsehen und Drama und
alles das Ultimative ist  aß
Vater, der ihre Töchter schlägt, und Sie
wissen und kontrollieren sie gerne und sind
gewalttätig, und das haben wir im Film oft gesehen,
wenn es darum geht,
die Männer des Nahen Ostens vorzutrainieren und
das Bild zu wiederholen, das so entsteht, ist
Männlichkeit  ist und so sollte ich
sein und wie und ich denke, das ist nicht wahr,
denn wir, das ist sicherlich, das existiert,
ist fehl am Platz, da
ihre Erfolgskultur existiert, es existiert auf
Carotinoid, es existiert, aber auch bei
ihnen existiert es, wie Menschen es mögen  mein
Vater und der Vater meines Freundes, die
nett und unterstützend sind, aber
wir feiern sie nicht, weil es
nicht viel ist, ist es nicht gut für das Drama.
Manchmal ist es ein einfaches Drama, den
Bösewicht wie den Vater zu haben, der die Familie kontrolliert, die
er ist  Es ist wirklich wichtig
, auch diese Art von Mann, Mädchen und
die Schwestern von den Inseln zu feiern, die ich
nicht nachahme, nachdem ich England verlassen habe, als
ich Takata verließ
t et hi Misha
strömte, ich weiß, Sie können blühen Saudi R&D
das ingham-Zeugnis Percy und der gemeine
Mann Zack entwarfen 2004 die
saudi-arabische Inflationswährung des Außerirdischen
nicht 14 noch Sohn Seite Punkt für die
Höhlen der Erde würde kein Datum finden, das ich
möchte  Sie können mich nach meinem Telefon fragen, in
Ordnung, ich bin nicht da, um
die Produkte und Filme von jemand anderem zu kommentieren, wenn
ich einen Film mache, der mein ist, was, wie ich
zur Veränderung beitrage und wie ich
mich selbst darstelle, und mein Film handelt von einem
jungen Menschen  Saudisches Mädchen, das versucht, ihre Stimme zu finden,
natürlich, dass mein
Film in Saudi-Arabien gezeigt wird,
ja, Vanya hat Thunfisch, wir haben ihn in
Venedig gezeigt, er wird im Mai gezeigt, es
wird so viel geben, dass es ein Film ist,
der viel Humor hat  hat viel Musik,
es ist eine Geschichte, die viel Herz hat,
und ich denke, es ist wirklich wichtig, das
Publikum zu begeistern. Ich bin in Saudi-Arabien aufgewachsen,
wo es kein Publikum gibt, kein
Kino, also für mich und wenn ich ein
Telefon mache, das ich will  einen Film zu machen, der so
unterhaltsam ist  macht Spaß und erzählt eine
Geschichte, und ich denke, wenn Sie
Menschen begeistern und ihr Herz berühren und sie
wirklich verändern möchten, müssen Sie sie unterhalten
Auch wenn ich kein
konfrontativer Mensch
bin, möchte ich die Leute nicht aus ihrer Komfortzone drängen,
und das ist für
mich die Rolle der Kunst
, die Atmosphäre zu schaffen, in der Dinge
passieren. Dieses Highschool-Zeug ist eine Art
Von politischen Ereignissen hat keine Kunst politische
Relevanz, aber Kunst ist kein Aktivismus, Kunst ist
unterhaltsam wie die Seele und
schafft hoffentlich eine entspannte Umgebung,
in der Menschen lernen, und das ist sehr
wichtig, Sie
können eine Umgebung schaffen, die entspannt
und tolerant ist und offen für Veränderungen ist
Musik und Literatur und Philosophie und
all das, was einen Menschen ausmacht,
der die Fähigkeit hat
, sich der Welt zu öffnen und zu lernen, und ich fühle, dass meine
Rolle als Künstler darin besteht, dies einzubringen,
um einen Humor einzubringen  Und um Spaß zu bringen, Musik einzubringen, um solche
Dinge zu bringen und
hoffentlich Menschen zu berühren, ist es nicht so
, als würde man Menschen nur aus ihrer Komfortzone drängen,
eine Zeit des Wandels ist sehr schwierig, die
Menschen werden nervös und sie behaupten
durch ihre Werte, dass es eine Art gutes
Klopfen ist  14 Ich war meine Nanny-Ikone und unser
Casting-Video-Café für
Salah-Schwester, aber es ist ein Film
und dies ist ja
zuerst eine Frau aus dem Auto bekannt
mit ihrer Bio-Kraftstoff-belüfteten Animation, die
Patel draußen ist, ja, Müll in der Öffentlichkeit
, Sie in die heißeste Anakonda Andra
Vitas und Götter und O's Ausgabeliste einbezieht,
beginnt in
Mateesah  Filme sind sehr, sie haben
immer wichtige Themen, aber sie werden
auf eine Weise erzählt, die Spaß macht,
unterhaltsam ist und und es war wie
du zu schreiben  ah, ich möchte einen Film machen, der zu
Hause gefeiert wird und
hoffentlich in Saudi-Arabien in die Kinos kommt
und viele junge Mädchen hingehen und sich
selbst sehen und Maryam und viele Männer
hingehen und sich selbst sehen und den Vater und
all das, aber auch  Ich würde es lieben, den
Film in der Schweiz in Zürich zu eröffnen,
und das ist mein Traum als Filmemacher,
ein breiteres Publikum zu erreichen, also wird das Schreiben des
Schreibprozesses wirklich
kompliziert, weil Sie eine Situation haben, die
manchmal sehr lokal ist und Sie
sie öffnen möchten  Welt und
ohne eine Fanta City zu verlieren, deshalb
schreibe ich ein Projekt wie
dieses, was willst du mit Humor haben
und du willst eine Kultur öffnen, die
manchmal sehr weit entfernt und
für die Außenwelt nicht zugänglich ist  Die Welt ist
nicht einfach und der Versuch
, bedeutungsvolle Situationen ohne Authentizität zu schaffen,
ist sehr wichtig. Sie würde nicht
tausend
gleiche Beträge im Jahr in einem
Herzen versuchen, um aus dem Lösungs-
Hockey-Universum, das es ist, ein Okay zu geben  Das Alpha der Carbon-
Saison hat viel gebracht. Ich bemühe mich wirklich die
ganze Zeit, der
jungen Generation von Filmemachern Möglichkeiten zum
Filmemachen in Saudi-Arabien zu bieten, weil wir
keine Industrie haben, die wir nicht haben, die
wir nicht haben, wie sie ist  Es ist manchmal schwierig für
Produzenten für internationale Produzenten, nach
Saudi-Arabien zu kommen und einen Film zu drehen,
weil wir keine em und
dusty haben, das ist wie Leute, die
ausgebildet sind und all das, also ist es für
jüngere Filmemacher schwieriger, mit
den Ressourcen besser zu werden  einen Film zu machen, der nicht
reist und nicht nur lokal ist, also
hoffe ich immer,
diesen jungen Filmemachern Möglichkeiten zu bieten
, die Produzenten zu finden, um ihre
Stimme zu schärfen, ihnen die Finanzierung zu geben, um eine Arbeit am Drehbuch zu schreiben, und ihnen
Rundflüge zu ermöglichen, über die ich gesprochen habe  Weißt du, Penny
Kites, du hast mich bei anständigen Filmkünstlern,
und ein Fackelgeräusch ist ein Produkt, das
ich nicht aussende und in etwas
ablenke. Ich habe den Film eingereicht, und
jeder arbeitet mit den Behörden zusammen, wenn
du  Wenn du nach Saudi-Arabien zurückkehrst, musst du
das Drehbuch einreichen und die
Erlaubnis bekommen, in
Saudi-Arabien zu drehen, und ich denke, es ist sehr
wichtig für mich, meinen Film in
Saudi-Arabien zu drehen, weil es eine Welt ist, die
niemand sieht  und und wenn ich nach
Saudi-Arabien gehe und arbeite, arbeite ich an einem Ort,
an dem es sehr gut ist. Ich arbeite mit
Laiendarstellern und versuche,
viel Intimität in den Film einzubringen,
weil ich es lieben würde, wenn die Leute Saudi sehen
Arabien weg von der Politik und den
Nachrichten und all dem, also muss jeder, der
mit ihnen in Saudi-Arabien arbeiten will,
durch dieses Büro gehen
und sich unterwerfen und so tun,
wie ja, und Saudi-Arabien ist
so und wann konservativ  Ich schreibe auf
Saudi, ich weiß, dass es eine Menge Dinge gibt
, die ich aufhören und hinzufügen und respektieren muss,
und ich würde das gerne respektieren,
weil es mir ermöglicht, zu
Hause gehört zu werden und hoffentlich die
Perspektive zu erweitern und
denke, es ist wie sehr manchmal gibt es
wie ich f  Aal, es gibt einen Antagonisten von
Ihren Fragen, wie zum Beispiel, dass Sie
dies tun, als würden Sie anklagen, es gibt einen
anklagenden Ton, und es
drängt Künstler wie mich, die versuchen
, wirklich etwas zu verändern, und in
Saudi-Arabien, und es wird nicht geschätzt
Es ist eine schwierige Situation, weil
es für uns als Künstler wirklich schwierig
ist, einen sinnvollen Film zu machen, und Sie
möchten ein breiteres Publikum erreichen, und
deshalb ist es sehr wichtig,
Kunst in Saudi-Arabien
zu unterstützen  Unterstützen Sie alle liberalen Werte und
progressiven Werte, die dort passieren,
und sprechen Sie die farc obszönen
Bräuche aus, die unser Brighton
für ein Album in den USA verzögern würden  Ich vermisse den
College Highway aus aufrichtigem Vertrauen und
dachte, ja, natürlich vermisse ich
Saudi-Arabien sehr. Ich gehe und besuche meine Mutter, meine
und meine Mutter lebt zu Hause in einer kleinen
Heimatstadt, und besuche sie. Ich habe das
Essen vermisst und war meine Schwestern  und meine Verwandten
und es ist sein Zuhause, also ja,
natürlich vermisse ich eine Menge Dinge,
die Pathan sich für jeden Fitnesswahn wünschen kann
- Mansoor, danke, wir haben uns mehr beworben, es
war Pentamer-Saudi-Araber, bis unsere
riesige Mahalia Tanana-Miliz-Stylistin ist
Film in Maha Limits Audition
Woodson, seine Salbung im Weißen Haus, erhält seine Arbeit
in Portland, um absolut ein absurdes
Orpheum 11, enthält ihren Film im
echten Saudi-Arabien, dokumentiert sogar den
konkurrierenden Reagan in der englischen Sprache
und hält Sultana privat und Blake
Lindas führende und als Audition Meter
steht  vertraut
[Musik]
du